bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est un
livre à berlin où fofana eva maeva un
produit qui est vraiment top
est ce que tu peux nous présenter ce
qu'était alors il s'agit de l'as les
deux plus grands vins
rien justement tri sur la pac
il s'agit d'une ardoise numérique qui
nous permet de
lisez tous les des sans papiers dont
contre maintenant à voir ce qu'elle paie
de famille n importe quel carnation
respecte et ensuite on peut utiliser nos
trois protistes dessin et mm de haut
deux vagues sur notre crayon comme ceci
cette bague on peut la mettre sur nous
et après on dessine donc sur du papier
avec des outils traditionnels mais on a
la version digitale
l'ipad
à la différence des gir et des outils
qu'on peut trouver numérisés c'est pas
un stylo qu'il est dit on prend vraiment
acheté beaucoup actuellement donc c'est
ça la grande différence
la plupart des tablettes graphiques ou
des outils qui existent déjà dans ce
domaine là on utilise nos propres outils
de dessin dont on garde une experte en
tic et naturel de dessin traditionnel
avec notre petit préféré end car des
progrès
si l'eau était préféré mais pas pour
autant sacrifier
total parce que comme on a la preuve et
ajoute on a tous les avantages
entretiennent avec la technologie
format de papier on est sur quelque elle
telle taille sur lui à saint combat là
on a favorisé ce normal pour le début
parce que ça permet d'être devant à
l'envers
parfois être regardés
et moi avec
avec nous faire des croquis notes été
dit teixeira et ensuite à forcer les
dessins que nous rendent
voir se connecte à la prison
je n'étais là j'ai un 4 gigas de mémoire
de nos ya le côté qui est hyper sexy ce
que tu montres que tu as fait un dessin
et après on peut voir le replay du
décembre qu'on peut vraiment voir de
quelle manière tu as créé sa structure
est en descente voilà c'est fait on peut
exporter un petit m lab de la création
du premier train jusqu'au dernier ce qui
est super par exemple est beaucoup moins
comment ça a été trop
faire des petits films assistant pas
donc on a la possibilité dans l'outil de
choisir différentes tailles de crayon
l'investisseur a craqué au papier par
exemple mettre autre chose en tant que
médecin mine un peu plus épaisse on peut
changer la couleur c'est parce qu'il a
ses fans en fait on peut dessiner par
exemple trouvé avec un stylo noir ou
avec un crayon mais après dans
l'application dire leur fait moi je veux
un feutre avec en train de mijoter
derrière le plus grand de ne pas citer
de 4 ans est en fait une couleur votre
voix quand donc si on
qui est vraiment jeu
avec ses rangs du tout avoir
c'est un pur régal
les gagnants sont les fleurs
parce que si tu va mener un projet dans
photo charles tu peux avoir été multi
calque les réorganiser
exportatrice de chasse fabien
directement avec lequel qu'on attend
d'être appelé son talent créatif et un
autre par otage ces questions-là flafla
cette marche aussi en mode tablette
graphique la conception qu'on peut
l'utiliser
des zurichois
ap et croyant comme un peu de choix
déterminé
une applique et ios android j'imagine
elle est sur un ios mac et pc androïd
sortait mieux pousser une tablette qui a
calqué sensations
qu'on laisse à votre site je suis dans
la description voilà et donc le patron
de la cei vient avec une slate serait ce
qu on voit très bien la europa et qui
vient avec nous flames un cri avec un
petit sac qu'on peut mettre sur d'autres
d'autres ayons un stylo un petit carnet
et en ce moment on note aussi la cour
on a développé une gamme d'accessoires
en fait pour aller avec le kit de
l'explorateur articulant même poussé
crayon c'est l'autre
baky pardon et blanc
mais avec lui donc
titan ligue mais on est aussi en
discussion
à tanger
les apôtres
merci madame merci et à bientôt vous
mettez tous un commentaire si vous êtes
graphiste vous décidez vous aimé
dessiner
il ya effectivement un amateur et
professionnel vous ne marquez en
commentaire pour cette se produisent que
vous l'avez déjà essayé au oui non et
puis on entre dans les commentaires
merci à vous quant à moi je vous dis à
très bientôt
salut